so we're trying to get you to the next
level okay
so marshley I know he had he has to keep
moving right if he stops then that's
where the person counters because my
control points will stop controlling him
he can move around right
uh and we know for example that oh my I
should be able to uh rebound and apply
the Coq uh we should know if I should
not be group dependent here there's
there's an adhesion that I'm using uh I
can move him around okay we know all
that
now look where we're at
is
in order to do all that or while doing
all that or concentric with doing all
that I am rotating the tanden field
uh as described in yesterday's video
okay and that's all your keyhonawasa all
of your King on waza is going to do that
if it even if it's not your Keyhole was
like you should be doing it okay meaning
it's another technique outside of that
curriculum okay
still do this okay
so as I go out
that time didn't feel is going to spin
to the right
going up
turning to the left and going down
it's the exact here's kokidosa and it go
I'm going to throw them to the left so
the energy field goes to the right goes
up turns to the left and goes down
all that's happening same thing here
okay now I'm coming in
right and I'm gonna do this same thing
again on this arm on actually the same
side okay Boom come around and now your
technique's gonna have you do it on the
other side so I come back
come back coming up and around and down
now the trick is that I don't ever stop
that spinning of that energy
doesn't stop
I don't stop
that tonden field
is constantly rotating
in that rotating crossbar
both sides
bone directions I mean
so the energetic component is concentric
with the physical component which means
that the energetic component
is concentric with the Marshall
component
so what I'm seeing here is as you become
fixated on the arm and you stop the
energetic component
this arm is now on the right side
of my Center can you see that right and
I can't get this step from where I'm at
to actually have this elbow on my Center
so she would have the Marshall Advantage
because I don't have an angle
cancellation on this arm this arm was
supposed to be over here now I have the
angle cancellation via the arm over here
I don't you see and then
energetically when I try to step it all
falls apart you see and I stepped into
her available line of attack and she has
the mechanical advantage she's just get
up he's
so I just
I just and you're always now in the
right place you see you see how I did
that and then the same thing happens
here when you go for the arm
you stop the energetic pattern
you see you just push this down
go back where we were
okay
you don't actually have
the power there
to do that
don't okay
and you've left her still
you see so she can move
and change my control points the nature
of them
so don't get fixated on the arm because
you that's where you lose all the
martial aspects as you not employ the
energetic aspects so when you're here
you gonna do the turn again
you see and then the arm is there
so a lot of you I'm watching
and you go
here
just do the energetic component again
and you move her body around
so this UK was laying down for you but
this you can now
coming around you see
because I'm just doing
the energetic spiraling okay